su abogada ha dicho que va a pelar a la
corte de casación Pues antes de que la
presidenta de la corte entregara El
veredicto ella dijo que Nicolás arcoí
como expresidente tenía que ser ejemplar
tenía que haberse comportado ya que se
le paga todavía un dinero de manera
vitalicia que viene de los
contribuyentes franceses de manera
ejemplar y no haber hecho esto lo que se
le acusa que es de tráfico de
influencias y de corrupción y también
que él y sus dos acusados como también
eran hombres de derecho deberían haber
sabido en su momento que estaban
incumpliendo la ley de que es el acusa
justamente en una época él en el año
2014 se le estaba investigando en otra
causa por el supuesto financiamiento
libio de su campaña del año 2007 y se
descubrió que tenía un tercer teléfono
estaba bajo escucha se descubrió que
tenía uno tercero bajo una identidad
falsa era el nombre de la persona
supuestamente propietaria de ese
teléfono y al escucharlo se vio que él
Estaba tratando de obtener información
de este fiscal de la corte de casación a
cambio de ayudarle para obtener un cargo
en Mónaco